i'm not going to apologize for telling a
guy to move fast if you don't want me to
speak again that's your
problem but i'm not going to ask for
forgiveness that's why you're asking for
forgiveness from me you piece of
i wanted to add that
who is reading this should eat my balls
that's all
that was that was really crossing the
line
um
i don't even know what to say
in chess.com justice system the people
are represented by two separate yet
equally important groups the fair play
team who investigate and close the
accounts and the support team who handle
the irate offenders these are their
stories
international master danny wrench chief
chess officer with chess.com back again
to respond to some tickets some
questions all the comments we get from
our amazing community members and this
time i'm here with sean arne director of
fair play
your director now
apparently apparently you've been taught
me that part of here we are here to dive
in and have a lot of fun just kidding me
and sean have known each other a while
so forgive the sass and it's time for us
to jump in to some questions
what kind of assistance did you use i
let someone else use my account tell us
more about the outside assistance you
used my friend played on my account i
used outside assistance because it
wasn't assistance if i was drunk and
passed out on the floor
wow
i feel personally attacked by that one
but uh
don't let your friend use your account
and be careful around alcohol
yeah
that's very good word and advice i i
often play on my phone maybe after
um
well let's move on from that yep
thank you for providing me with an
excellent chess experience during the
last 10 or so years that i've used this
site i have one small issue however me
and my main man have frequent and
furious chess games where in our passion
we accidentally hit the resign button
since it is next to the analyze button
and one of us accidentally leaves like a
lover who leaves the comfort of the
bedroom before the deed is done we both
feel an extreme emptiness when this
happens
may i suggest moving the resign button
elsewhere so we can reach our chess
climax uninterrupted thank you very much
oh my god
um
reaching your chest climax is one of the
most important parts of playing chess
online so i'm going to say that i feel
you did you know
that you can use protection
when you're when you're playing chess
online there's an option
to be asked when you click the resign
button to confirm resign so click on
your settings
enable that protection before you engage
in future
chess loving affairs i'm trying to walk
this line very carefully here and when
you check that box it will ask you have
you truly reached climax or not
if not you can continue your game and
that's the best way i could answer that
yeah i mean danny it's like you always
say you got to practice safe chess
i practice safe chess we believe in safe
chess on chess.com and if you're not
practicing safe chess
you know you
go somewhere else i was gonna make a
rhyme if you're not practicing save
chess go talk to robert pass but uh
go dr rob that's freaking genius i'm
gonna write that down you're not
practicing safe chess go talk to robert
hess
hi i'm wondering that is it against fair
play rule that i use engine to play with
my friends just to troll them unranked
of course i know it's a dick move but i
just personally to troll them if this is
against the rule and have a chance to
get my account ban i will stop this i
just want to clarify things thank you in
advance
okay well hi
right back at you uh i appreciate the
question i love trolling as long as you
tell your friends you are allowed to use
engines in unrated games great question
sounds like a great friend
thank you i wrote a poem about why i
cheated i'll put it in here for laughs
life at 1
200 was quite simple though my rating
started to dwindle i thought how could i
stop getting beat oh i know i'll cheat
it's been a couple months since i was
being dishonest i must admit my method
was not the smartest now i know that
cheating is not okay because i got
banned for fair play
i appreciate the poem i'm not sure i can
approve of rhyming's smartest and honest
also i think instead of just saying
cheat you could have said something like
i decided to give my opponent a treat
and then i went out to find the best
dish which of course led me to use stock
fish but please don't cheat on the site
first of all
harry mack watch out we got sean arn
director of fair play crushing it over
here also yeah i agree i think the
biggest takeaway from that was not just
that he cheated but that he rhymed
honest and smartest what does he think
he is eminem write us a better poem and
we'll let you back
there you go get back to work
dearest sirs and madams i am writing you
on this day the 18th day of september
the year of our lord
2021 to express and grieve with you over
the most inconvenient of annoyances
you see someone has barred me from using
swears on the chess.com app and has most
recently barred me from speaking to my
friends entirely
this is furry
it is complete horse
and i will tell you why number one
[Laughter]
in conclusion i ask that my account's
ability to send messages be unfair and
in the name of civility and decency that
further attempts to silence my friendly
profanity-laced conversations be
themselves
good day
oh man it's always easy to spot a dota
player in the wild so
that guy uh also i feel like i should
give
a much longer response but i really
can't i'll just
have a nice day have a really nice day
man
i will actually go on record for saying
i do believe there is a time and a place
for a for a a curse word to be used i
believe that it is a
sometimes proper reflection of uh
putting the correct emphasis on the
right syllable if you will
that said
um there has to be there has to be some
lines in context so while i appreciate
the argument um it's important that um
that overall we we do our best online to
communicate in the most efficient manner
which often doesn't include
profanity-laced
uh statements you're absolutely right
danny i mean
we sign off all of our meetings with
profanities so there is a high man place
for them yeah
right back at you buddy
since you muted me indefinitely for
bullying people in chat in cancelling my
premium membership and switching to
lyceus where they let me be toxic
good for you
yeah yeah congratulations
you gotta do what you gotta do
right
yeah yeah you know
league and dota players
go flock over there you can be toxic
go flock your way to some toxicity over
there and do your best
with your life
i am professional chess player gm ding
leeron i had recently started a private
youtube channel to record some games of
my speedrun journey on chess.com my
account name is
however my chess.com account has been
closed for an unknown reason while
playing a game i am estimating the
problem might have been using engines
and computers this is not true i was
trying my hardest to get my rapid rating
up i hope you understand the situation
positively and give a quick response p.s
i know you are a robot
leeran all you had to do was email me
and tell me you're gonna do it now i get
it dude let's reopen his account
obviously that's him i've gotten a few
emails from him that's exactly how he
talks and of course he's into the
speedrun game everyone gets it he's a
professional chess player i get you lee
wren live we're opening it i got you
buddy game recognized game
i was not aware of this rule i honestly
wanted to get my score as low as
possible thinking there might be a
secret achievement
i love secret achievements and you are
trotting a a well-trodden path lots of
people have plumbed those depths before
you just try to play at your own rating
level
unlock you are the worst chess player in
the world secretary on chess.com get
your rating as low as possible i love
that idea
yeah you know i've had a similar thing
where i lost a game and it recommended
me a lesson on the form of checkmate so
we're probably in the same boat that
always feels good right
i love that okay yeah so secret
achievements are hidden everywhere but
we do not have ones that encourage you
to lose chess games pro tip
i lost my rating because of your glitch
in the app i put my pawn to step ahead
and the pawn left to me cut that pawn ah
you know we have a patch coming out on
april 1st be there on april 1st on
passant will no longer be allowed i was
wondering where we would get to our
first on passant ticket that was a good
one right there um yeah so april 1st
tune in and uh you won't have to deal
with this bug anymore it just it takes
some time for us to do so on april 1st
it'll be fixed
highcheese.com i only ask you may think
twice when you promote levy rosem gotham
cheese on chess.com a wonderful
wonderful service the general public are
getting sick of levy his stupid faces
pure isle arrogant and elitist
commentary at al so today i was sad to
see today his face on the front of
chess.com's website this is actually a
deal breaker if it continues for me and
i feel chess.com may be losing some of
its identity please read on
[Laughter]
i am very saddened to see him here too
on the landing page can i not escape
this idiot
levy is not a mature enough or grown up
enough to be ambassador for chess this
is my opinion but of course you don't
have to agree with me but please take
something from what i have expressed on
board when you consider his affiliations
with chess.com for the love of chess
sorry to lumber this on you
chess.com is super great otherwise
i i want to first acknowledge that a lot
of time and effort was put into that
message right there and i think uh like
a lot of the comments on levy's youtube
channel um everyone is entitled to their
own opinion
there are a lot of uh people who might
have a different opinion uh contrary to
that one
i'm trying to be politically correct
when i say
levy's here to stay
i mean great use of of pure isle that
was awesome did i i rhymed accidentally
poet didn't know it
didn't know it
crushed it take that
hello please unban me i have played so
much hour of chess in this app more than
1 500 games and i was going to buy the
premium version sooner or later i just
playing chess with my brain i seriously
don't know why you ban me at the moment
i'm very lucky in a lot of things it's
just that and if i buy the premium
version right now it's automatically
unburned
he's negotiating that's
he's
yeah i mean you've really got me over a
barrel here i need that i need that cash
like
i'm gonna lose my job after this danny's
gonna fire me so i need that
i need a little bit of extra money to
pay the bills this month
you're reinstated
that's the thing is you know you'd have
to cut yourself in front of that deal
which might be a good future lucrative
side job for you is
telling people if they go free move
you'll unban and then you ban them again
twist ending we treat premium members
the same
yeah it really is a democracy that's
chess.com but if you venmo me ten
dollars
oh man
hi all
yesterday i was playing lots of chess
which made my girlfriend quite mad
now i find my account closed which she
admitted to have done in anger i was
hoping for the possibility to restore my
account somehow thanks
oh man it was wow we got brought in
there we're in that we're in the
relationship issues now we got brought
here i
feel like i'm on relationship advice
right now and i'm in no position to give
advice
i will say that no device or game
including the greatest of all time the
game of kings should should separate you
from other people right it shouldn't be
a distraction from real life so i
definitely stand by your girlfriend um
from that point of view that said i
don't believe it's right to take matters
into your own hands and close someone's
account so i think if they were both
validating each other's feelings right
in a different way we might not have
gotten to this point
um that would be my advice
i hear you danny and i feel supported
so after my last complaint i got a free
diamond membership for a month to
compensate my problem unfortunately
everything seems to be working fine now
i don't have any complaints but that
doesn't change the fact that i have
gotten too used to analyzing my games
and enjoying the unlimited puzzles so i
request you to please grant me another
free diamond membership please thank you
ps make it to annual membership this
time
that's
that's a solid argument and we do
appreciate that going premium uh allowed
you to get more more access and use out
of the tools i don't know what it was
before that you were unhappy about that
got our amazing support team member to
give you free diamond i would recommend
the way you circumvent the system is
figure out another thing to complain
about right support and then they'll
give you a new diamond membership pro
tip
that's smart that's smart that's a big
brain big brain play right there
had chess.com started to trust cheaters
and gave them a warning two or three
times that they know they are cheating
they would have obviously been scared
and feared that they had been watched
they would have rather lived in fear of
their accounts get banned than actually
cheating and hoping they could get away
with it this is what i please chess.com
for
if they could at least trust the
cheaters like me and gave them a final
chance they could have better lived off
in the fear of getting banned for
cheating and obviously won't cheat
because it will be their last chance of
redemption while enjoying chess and
playing fairly
this is just the modern ages answer to
jonathan swift's a modest proposal uh so
many
things that i'd like to challenge there
if we gave you a warning why would you
cheat two or three more times down the
line
that's what i'll go with you know i
might reject that proposal
i i don't even know where to go with
that i um that was that was brilliant
and um
noted thank you for the feedback
i'll be sure to pass that right along
i'm watching your video of weirdest
support feedback and since a lot of the
feedback is negative i just want to make
sure the team receives a positive note
too thank you danny sean and everyone
else at chess.com for helping to grow my
interest in chess over the last year and
making such a wealth and variety of
information easily accessible and
approachable i've especially appreciated
the lessons and puzzles which helped
make chess so much more concrete to me
after finding it inscrutable and
daunting for decades prior i'm so
grateful that chescom's presence on
twitch has encouraged me to try chess
for myself and find welcoming
communities of players doing the same
your work is appreciated
dad is that you
i was expecting a twist there somehow
he's like where's the twist yeah this is
a trick
oh my gosh i thought it was gonna be
thank you so much and that's why i
choose to play on lead chess but no i
really appreciate that one
oh man it's so good that was a really
good one to end with
yeah
you should be able to talk people all
the time right
those 40 year olds knew it when they
were talking to eight-year-old me
oh do you want to talk about anything is
it are you
i didn't know you you were carrying
around so much baggage for a
four-year-old who verbally abused you i
think we both know the name we're
talking about james dingle that he
flip-flopped through the roof
sorry inside joke um to a local chess
player in arizona where where uh where
shawn grew up and i was his first chess
coach okay now they know the truth
this is how i got the
job actually i've been trying to get him
fired since we hired him for a long time
but somehow he's doing doing good enough
so that's why you invited me to the
video to finally get enough
incriminating evidence
oh man
[Music]
you